any tips on learning about indirect
communication would be handy for
business or parenting I've got another
parent I got a million parenting
questions yes you know avoiding like I
was saying that that's kind of why you
can't really just talk about something
because there's actually if you want to
quantify the parenting questions is
infinity good question there's no end to
the parenting question because it's just
so ambiguous I don't know really good
line is the bottom line is parenting is
leadership so the principles can be
applied yes but there are some dynamics
there and they're all in your own head
yeah that's where they are there you're
in your own head as a parent they're
this emotional thing that you have
stronger than you have it for any other
person you're ever gonna work with and
that is you know you want them to
succeed more than anybody else yeah you
want them to succeed you want them to be
better you want them to do better you
all those things and that's the dynamic
that makes it tricky yeah
and then there's this weird dynamic - of
the way they look at you and they either
want to impress you or they want to
rebel against you or they see you as
being a you know imposing on them so
there's just these other dynamics you
know within the leadership confines that
are that are very challenging and again
I can't judge whether I've been
successful yet because I only have up my
oldest daughter is 16 and the youngest
daughters six and and then I have a
daughter and another daughter so in the
middle and then I know that there are
specific mistakes that I have made I
know that and I you know then mistakes
like what does that mean you know I mean
of course you know because if you go to
extreme but because really successful or
I don't say success but really driven
people people were just you know how you
get somebody who's driven but it's
usually usually because some need
so during development wasn't fulfilled
and I'm not saying and you can't even
say it's a bad thing because as a result
they're driven because psychologically
it's like a need that needs to be
fulfilled so since that little cup
remain kind of empty a little bit
there's trying to fill it with all these
other things because life went on new
skills new developments new situations
and they're still trying to fill that
little
illogical Cup and it's manifesting in
this other way you know through business
through you know being a Navy SEAL
jiu-jitsu champion you know whatever it
may be but yeah but typically and I'm
saying every single time I'm sure
there's exceptions or maybe there's not
exceptions I don't know but nonetheless
you can usually find some need that went
unfulfilled somewhere for people who are
super driven so if you made a mistake
parenting is was that really a mistake
you know in that kind of situation so
like as it's it's so ambiguous you know
you think you like what is a successful
parent yeah that's my point that's why I
don't want to talk to you about
parenting because I don't know I don't
feel like an authority on it right that
should be yeah giving instruction yeah
it's hard to even how can you be I mean
I think I'm doing an okay job well yeah
so you figure if they're not in jail or
super addicted to like drugs or
something like this or then you can say
okay I'm I think I think in my opinion
I'm within the confines of being a
successful and you know what since we're
talking about it you see some kids
I've known kids your kids I grew up with
with nice parents and all that and they
go off the rails and that's really
skinny of you do you blame the parents I
mean I don't know in my opinion it's
because of the parents yes but that's
not the question do you blame the
parents I don't know we got a question
on here about in nature-nurture so I'm
gonna talk about that here in a minute
but indirect communication let's get
back to this so indirect communication
is obviously extremely powerful it's
also tricky to pull off because you
can't let your emotions show and you
can't just speak your mind you have to
think about what you're gonna say you
have to think about how it will be
received and understood by the person or
by the people that you're talking to you
gotta put yourself into their shoes in
hear it from their perspective and
that's really hard to do and the other
piece about this another piece to think
about if you're trying to improve your
indirect
communication go into your conversations
with a goal not just a goal of the
conversation itself but it a strategic
goal of what you're trying to accomplish
a commander's intent why are you having
this conversation what is the endgame
what is the end state where are you
trying to what are you trying to make
happen yeah and keep that in mind as you
talk to this person or this group of
people and then read and react to see
how you're saying and and how much what
you're saying is leading to the end
state that you're looking for
because sometimes we just think about
the conversation itself and the
conversation itself doesn't matter what
are you trying to do in the end state
it's like we talked about before a few
podcasts ago the argument that you're
having whether you're right or whether
you're wrong
doesn't matter what matters is the end
state where you trying to get this to be
what are you how you trying to influence
this person and remember that the best
way to win is for your opponent to not
even realize that there's a debate
that's the best way to win and you get
some people some people instinctively
counter everything that you say you know
they have a response they have a thing
they they've got a counter everything
that you say don't do that if you want
to work on your indirect communication
skills absorb what they're saying right
the best way to get better at indirect
communication is to listen listen not
talk but listen and as a matter of fact
when you sit back and you let people
talk you're progressing so much because
most people don't want to listen most
people want to run their mouths and if
you ever find yourself running your
mouth you should put yourself in check
because you're giving away too much
information and so you want to listen
you want to try and actually understand
what they're saying and here's another
good one if you don't understand what
they're saying just ask them
to explain it again mm-hmm hey kit can
you can you explain that to me again
that missed it I don't understand
I would they why that implies that I
want to understand it implies that I'm
doing my best to understand it implies
that if I don't understand I'm gonna be
frank enough with you to tell you that
is how you get better than direct
communication because the more you
listen to somebody the better you
understand their position and when you
know where someone's position is the
better you can maneuver onto that
position the better you can get to a
flank the better you can make
adaptations and the better tactics you
have to win and that's how you get
better at indirect communication
yeah you mentioned how oh you don't like
if you don't listen and you know how how
you fail to put yourself in the other
person's shoes right this thing called
the curse of knowledge right so let's
say I'm this high level CEO sometimes we
tend to forget how it is to not be the
high level CEO or how it we forget how
it is to not know everything we know
that's the curse of knowledge like the
knowledge basically blocks you from
identifying someone who doesn't know you
know so and that goes into these weird
details you know how when you get enough
knowledge certain significant knowledge
becomes common sense to you but
meanwhile to everyone else it's not so
you just habitually or unconsciously you
might say skip over it right meanwhile
they don't really understand and then
you're just like ah you know I don't
know what I'm doing wrong kind of thing
let's go to the curse of knowledge you
gotta watch out for me what's up for the
crystal knowledge yes I like that